one week ago I set off an adventure into
the wilds of the northeast of India to
track down the fabulous dishes that are
unique to this region the Northeast is
very special and it's sort of the
opposite to I expecting I've discovered
that the food is completely different to
any of the Indian classics I've cooked
before yeah there's no guarantee I'll uh
you know there's no there's no there's
no powders it's all fresh fragrant free
little spice
now I've flown back to Calcutta where my
bad for my neck on the line northeastern
curries have never been sold on these
streets before
I'm going to use everything I've learned
to trade dishes that will show this city
what has been missing it's the crack of
dawn and our Pearlie to join your other
street cooks already preparing for a
busy lunch DJ now the streets starting
to get busy everyone's starting to sort
of get themselves organized and serene I
smell already so that he is on without
their 135,000 stalls my competition is
going to be tough my northeast Curry's
need to be good enough to turn customers
away from their tried and tested
favourites they wouldn't have seen or
discovered food like this before so I
just hope in the hell that they don't
turn their nose up against it because
they don't recognize oh that's not sort
of what we're used to and I've hired
some local lads to help me out how are
you good to see and this is so you said
it Zagat's are you sure they're not
bunking off school no no no definitely
not I didn't know him okay rush okay
first thing yeah I need the fire
lighting here I'm going to draw on the
unique flavors of the Northeast to
create three delicious curries my first
is chicken and green papaya inspired by
the winning recipe and the cooking
competition
it will have that classic a semi sour
tang that the locals won't be used to
bring papaya helps it not just soften
the chicken but marinade it also gives
that really nice tart flavor I'm going
to make your fish curry using the dried
bamboo shoot from Nagaland it's
something of an acquired taste and I
don't know how we'll go down here this
combination of a sort of bay leaf stroke
lemongrass with a little hint of
licorice first time for you I'm so
pleased my final dish is a northeastern
take on vegetable curry instead of using
dried spices I'm using fresh ones making
it more subtle flavor fish with a puree
of sesame seeds almost thickened
vegetable curry with a sesame seed paste
and then after that the fresh coriander
paste just one last thing to do before I
open my store I'm sweating like a pig I
look like a pig I stink like a pig right
and we get changed they've done a new
similar in the white TV that is centered
on you see valid
a lot of our evitar garages how about
you devalue almogavar labonte oh thanks
cooler much better says not exactly chef
White's is it but I suppose it's cooler
to save my take on the Northeast can win
over you must tell them that chicken
mystery service' actually this is a new
thing to us and down at them I don't
know other people would like it or not
but in my opinion it's really a super
ones let's go let's go let's go
the food is very good and I have to face
with bamboo shoots it's very tasty
chokes the green papaya thank you yes
sir chicken papayas gone down a storm
the last chicken it's unbelievable
that's barely about 50 minutes over
unfortunate chicken's gone which is
fantastic you with the last the chicken
burp are gone my fish and vegetable
curries quickly sell out - sir thank you
that is now officially Gordon Ramsay's
Calcutta cafe closed it's been a great
day I've enjoyed myself and judging by
the reaction my curry has been a success
500 600 700 800 900 1000 yeah that my
son is a good mornings work ok yes every
people say the food is excellent today
yeah definitely everybody said that
but there's one person's opinion that
really matters food writer nan Don's
arrived to give me his verdict how are
you I'm good how was your week and my
week has been amazing so what did you
cooked up today so today we did a take
on a chicken and the green papaya we did
an amazing fish curry I staked a little
portion because I was getting slightly
worried
[Music]
no wonder you sold out thank you you
leave me
you happy with us not only that you have
actually succeeded in doing something
many people would have said is
impossible well done the French are so
very well that is very well done
I look ridiculous and must have lost
half my body weight in sweat but I've
proved that Curry's off the northeast of
India are worth shouting about
I thought my first week in India was a
iOpener this one was a shock I think
because it's hard to believe that exists
it was almost like you weren't in India
the culture is equally as exciting as
the food just an amazing eye-opener the
simplicity the concentration of great
ingredients and not pissing around with
it India's help me to you become you
know not just you know a proper chef
I've never I've never out that bracket
but it has helped me to confirm what I
love doing more than anything can we top
that I doubt it but I can't [ __ ] wait
to try